the men's ncaa national championship
game played tonight between baylor and
gonzaga sports books across the valley
were
open for business packed with spectators
in some cases
eight sports now kevin martin joining us
live with fan reaction
from the westgate book hey there kevin
well hey brian it has been exactly 200
or 728 days excuse me
since the last basketball national
championship game was played of course
because the 2020 ncaa tournament was
cancelled due to the covid pandemic
so as you can imagine who fans were
overjoyed that the wait was finally over
as people came out to the westgate
superbook to watch the action and place
bets on the two teams vying for the
title
something they were not able to do a
year ago at this time and although the
game wasn't a close one
with baylor jumping out to a 9-0 lead
and never looking back
86-70 was the final spoiling gonzaga's
dream of being an
undefeated champion but even though it
wasn't a thriller fans were still
thrilled to be back honestly it's
something that i just feel like i'm in
my natural habitat because
like this is what i do so it's amazing
especially when you're hitting bets
just to be able to see everybody to be
able to you know feel
free to roam around and have a drink and
just some normalcy
you know it's a good thing and we take
those small things for uh
for granted sometimes you know it's a
great thing
i totally agree it definitely felt like
a little bit of sense of normalcy was
back and
by the way this was baylor's first
national title game or program
in program history